when I was your age my mom likes to
remind me I could afford a house payment
car payment and college tuition without
going into debt and I worked as a
waitress
but that's not possible today when my
parents had their first child in 1980
the median income for an 18 to 34 year
old was around $36,000 today that median
income for the same age group is closer
to $34,000 and minimum wage has gone
down too
but while incomes have gone down the
price of most major expenses has gone up
in 1980 the average tuition at four-year
public colleges was only $2,400 a year
today those same schools cost more than
$9,000 and private schools are a whole
nother story the average new car in 1980
was less than $22,000 compared to
$33,000 today and you could get a house
in 1980 for an average cost of a hundred
and eighty six thousand dollars today a
house costs almost twice that so if the
price of everything has gone up so much
in the last 35 years what our paychecks
haven't kept up how can we be expected
to meet the living standards of our
parents
we're facing limited job prospects the
cost of living in America cities has
skyrocketed and we're up to our eyeballs
in student debt